[Music]
you're watching the press preview here
on sky news a first look at what's on
the front pages as they arrive into us
here at sky news over the next half an
hour we'll take a look at what's making
the headlines with the whitehall
legislature for the financial times
sebastian payne and the broadcaster and
former conservative special adviser
anita boateng and so let's take a look
at what's on some of those front pages
the ones that have come in so far the
metro first
rish versus rash uh referring to the
chancellor rishi sunax comments on
scrapping a temporary school holiday
food scheme despite pressure from the
footballer and campaigner marcus
rashford
the eye also preempted the chancellor's
budget speech on wednesday adding an
expected 6 billion pound plan with with
the aim of clearing the nhs backlog
let's take a look at the guardian it
carries comments from labour which
accuses the chancellor of smoke and
mirrors after he admitted only 20
percent of the money for levelling up
is new
that was the biggest announcement of
course wasn't it that money for
transport uh meanwhile the telegraph
claims modelling from scientific experts
predicts covered cases will peak soon
and for this winter without the need
for restrictions to be re-introduced
the sun
they have a royal exclusive they reveal
the queen was forced to miss church
today as she rested after spending a
night in hospital
the daily mail
an investigation by the newspaper says
it has found hundreds of drug dealers
with large followings using instagram to
sell cannabis to children
well as i said we're joined by sebastian
payne from the financial times and
broadcaster and former conservative
special adviser anita boateng and to
take a look at the front pages we have
so far good evening to you both
evening
both from very lovely front rooms i
still don't get over um looking into
people's front rooms all this time on as
we uh continue to talk uh by the power
of skype and such um let's start with
the daily telegraph shall we um covert
cases to slump in winter says scientists
sebastian a lot of people who will read
this tomorrow morning will be surprised
given um
some of the word that's come out from
sage for example the government's main
advisory scientific advisory board
saying the opposite
indeed well thank you very much sergey
i'm glad to hear you're a fan of the
curtains behind me um so this is a fun
page that i think sort of goes to what
some in government are thinking because
this week we had that press conference
from the health secretary sanji javid
the first covert press conference in
five weeks saying if people don't watch
their behavior and get booster jabs
we're gonna be into plan b which means
working from home vaccine passports
monitoring masks the telegraph explains
maybe why we haven't had that plan be
implemented yet despite the fact many
within the nhs and external health
advisors said we should this modeling
which the telegraph has seen suggests
that actually we're going to heat
something that is described as the um
the endemic equilibrium that would
basically suggest that coronavirus will
run out of people to infect it will hit
a wall of immunity and this does seem
totally plausible when you think about
the fact the office for national
statistics have said that 90 to 95 of
the country already have coronavirus
antibodies so when you compare to that
you say well hang on a minute it's
eventually going to hit some kind of
wall of immunity and this report
suggests that these internal papers show
that cases will soon peak and then fall
very rapidly in november now obviously
we've seen so many models throughout
this panda i mean who knows if this one
is correct but if it is it happens to be
right and i think many people and gone
will be absolutely delighted because
this would mean we get through the
winter with the nhs running at a much
lower capacity and still able to cope
with flu and the other things as well
but as i said we've had so many models
and so many things have been proved
wrong and i think you've got to take all
these things little slight pinch of salt
yeah i mean it is a positive headline
and people will read it and take it as
such but anita this feeds into the mixed
messaging that the public feel they are
getting from official bodies i mean um
the daily covert cases were predicted to
go well currently hovering around 50
000. the health secretary himself said
that could double by the winter period
and yet you here you have a group of
scientists
delivering better news you can
understand the public being very
confused going into this winter period
and that's why the government hasn't
made public at the moment this um
research which does seem as sebastian
says pretty plausible it's from the
london school of hygiene and tropical
medicine and um one of the figures
they've quoted there is from sage who
also said that they have expected a
decline coming into the autumn mostly
because a number of people have already
been infected so for instance for quite
a considerable period of time we've been
seeing lower numbers for london and and
what we think that is and the ons seems
to support this is that a lot of people
in london seem to already have caught
covered probably due to the summer of um
people isolating because of the fact
that they had coping so this is
incredibly encouraging news but i think
it's right that government messaging
continues to be that of trying to get
people to get their booster vaccines and
get people to be cautious yeah a record
day uh for the government in the
vaccination roll out let's take a look
at the daily mirrors headline tomorrow
uh get booster and save christmas uh
four million people sebastian have now
had a booster jab uh more people being
vaccinated in the run-up to christmas
a lot of people are you know resting
their christmas plans on the booster jab
and this continued vaccine rollout and a
lot of people anecdotally saying that
they're going to continue working from
home wearing masks through personal
choice in crowded spaces because
everybody's looking to a ver looking for
a very different christmas to enjoy to
the one we had last
i think that's right and i think
everyone is slightly scarred by what
happened last year because if we think
about it this is exactly the same
narrative that we have that it was
everything's fine everything's fine and
then suddenly we're in lockdown then we
came out of lockdown and then it was
christmas and then christmas was
cancelled again so you can understand
the general apprehension of people who
have seen these headlines from the
government saying it's all going to be
okay and most people think well it
wasn't okay last christmas so why is it
going to be okay this christmas well the
answer of course is that we've got the
vaccines which is office have totally
transformed the pandemic and they offer
so much protection against serious
illness from code that is quite
transformative but i think you know you
can see those case levels and if they do
increase and most importantly if they
increase and then sustain at a higher
level that is the problem for the nhs at
that level and really the message from
and professor stephen powers on the
front page of the mirror is saying the
boosters are the best weapons we have
and the data we had this week was eight
million people are eligible for boosters
and the most vulnerable categories of um
for covet so far four million have had
them which is great but there's 1.5
million people who are eligible and have
been asked but haven't yet taken them up
and those that people the government are
trying to get to and i think we'll see a
lot more effort for ministers because
for many in whitehall it's been see no
covet speak no covet hear no curve but
everyone's been trying to get on with
normal life and in some ways pretend the
pandemic is over when in fact we know it
isn't so i think you'll see a very sharp
change of messaging which started with
the press conference and will continue
throughout the winter but as you said
those numbers are very strong people
getting the boosters the question which
was raised in some of the sunday papers
is will under 50s get the booster as
well because at the moment they're
focused on just the most vulnerable
groups i think the question for
ministers is do we have the supply to
get more people the boosters and is that
inevitably where we're going to head
into and in fact that it's going to be
three jabs not two jabs to represent the
fully vaccinated because to me it kind
of feels inevitable at this point and
let's move on to the eye front page six
billion pound plan to clear the nhs
covid backlog anita a lot of talk about
the pressures uh on the nhs this winter
coming from covid but of course because
of the pandemic you know people are
coming down with flu other illnesses
that we didn't have because obviously
and everybody was on lockdown a lot of
people having treatment that had to be
delayed during the pandemic and so the
nhs is going to face pressure this
winter whatever way you look at it is
six billion pounds going to be enough
well i think that's indeed the question
and actually icu's generally tend to run
at about 80
capacity during regular winter so when
you add in the backlog of elective
surgery as well as the fact that you
know there seems to be a certain
percentage certainly in the kind of
maybe late teens of people with covert
occupying wards right now i think it is
an incredibly challenging situation for
the nhs i think what we're seeing is a
balance between um you know elective
activity which this money seems to be
going towards which is incredibly
important but also that diagnostic
element of um people waiting where
actually there's a lot of people waiting
for tests and that kind of thing which
aren't generally counted as being part
of kind of on waiting lists but actually
aren't quite in the same situation as
those waiting for kind of elective
surgery or all that kind of thing so i
think to me it feels as though this is
going to be an enormously challenging
winter almost regardless of the covert
element of this so the likelihood that
the nhs will be under considerable
strain i think it's something the
government is braced for
the guardian sebastian uh the chancellor
has been accused of smoke and mirrors
over his budget cash pledges so far this
all centers on the fact that already
it's been announced seven billion pounds
will be spent on areas outside of london
to level up transport he admitted to sky
news that only 1.5 billion of that is
actually new money
indeed and i think this always this is a
thing you get with budgets every year
that governments like to re-announce
things they've already said and
aren't quite clear and it's not until
wednesday when we get the budget
documents from the treasury we can
figure out how much new cash there is
and how much is just recycled
announcements and the general theme
you're going to see on wednesday though
is of a relatively okay fiscal picture
in the short term that it looks as if
you know people have been consuming tax
receipts are higher than the office for
budget responsibility expected which
means we should soon i can't splash the
cash a little bit even if we're not
quite clear where it's going to go but
when you pull back the camera lens and
look at the medium medium-term picture
then i think things are maybe not so
rosy we've still got obviously very
precarious public finances concerns
about inflation and potentially the
prospect of interest rates rising so i
think the message you'll hear from rishi
sunak will be positive but laced with
caution which is very different from his
budgets he's delivered so far as
chancellor which have so far has been
doling out oodles and oodles of cash and
to prop up the economy throughout the
kona virus pandemic but on this specific
question about clarity about where money
is going we'll find out the answers on
wednesday but clearly this is the last
budget the government has um if it
really wants to try and make progress on
its leveling up agenda to tackle
regional inequality and that seven
billion pound announcement that was made
for transport outside of london those
are the kind of headlines boris johnson
wants to get because he wants to say to
those first-time tory voters you voted
for me i'm giving you money and we're
trying to tackle these decades of
underspending in parts of england that
have often been left behind or felt to
be left behind but as the guardian front
page says the proof will be how much is
actually new capital investment and how
much is just the same amount of money
being recycled around yeah and we'll be
crunching all the numbers and finding
out what is new and what is old money
here on sky news on wednesday we're
going to take a break sebastian and
anita thank you very much for the moment
coming up we'll be discussing uh this
story which features on the front page
of the telegraph
major museums back antique woke charter
all that more coming up
[Music]
hello welcome back you're watching the
press preview here on sky news uh with
me tonight whitehall editor of the
financial times sebastian payne and
broadcaster and former conservative
special adviser anita boateng welcome
back both we're gonna head to the
business section of the daily telegraph
um anita i'll start with you first um
this story will send a shiver down the
spine
of parents facebook apps are used to
groom 24 children a week according to
the nspcc
uh and these are just the um offenses
that are reported anita
yes and this is going to be a quite
explosive select committee hearing um
that's going to take place tomorrow with
francis haugen the whistleblower it
feels to me as though you know nadine
dory's the new culture secretary has
placed front and center her feelings
about the obligations of the tech giants
and particularly of facebook um to take
action in terms of protecting
individuals and and questioning whether
or not the online safety bill which is a
major piece of legislation going through
parliament is going to need to be beefed
up in order to ensure that tech um
companies such as facebook take their
duties to protect people as well as to
ensure it's a kind of um
ensure free speech um that is actually
happening so it feels as though this is
going to be something that's front pages
for quite some time yeah sebastian um
anita mentioned there francis hogg and
the whistleblower the facebook
whistleblower she is powerful testimony
to congress in the states we covered it
live here on sky news and she described
this as the tobacco moment for social
media in america when people suddenly
realize how harmful cigarettes were and
there was a real shift in attitudes
she's going to give evidence in
parliament tomorrow
what do you think will be done because
the prime minister has pledged criminal
sanctions on tech giants responsible for
allowing harmful content as part of this
online safety bill
it's a very tricky one isn't it because
the uk does want to act on this and
following the tragic death of sir david
amos there was some very powerful
testimony in the house of commons from
mps who called for an end to anonymity
online and i completely share their
concerns but i'm still not quite sure
how you can actually do that that i
think you know mark franz while the m
the conservative backbencher mp he was
making the case that all elementary
should be banned in the that people
shouldn't be allowed to hide behind that
but again i'm not quite sure how exactly
you do that so when this legislation
comes up it'll be faintly where the
government lands there with some reports
in the sunday papers that nadine doris
is leading towards the arguments made
the likes by mr francois but i think um
practically that is going to be very
tough but i think this testimony that
you mentioned is going to be a very big
moment here that we know the social
media companies have acted in some very
concerning fashions they are not in my
view upholding their responsibilities as
publishers you know i work for a great
newspaper and we take everything very
seriously in terms of what goes in our
print paper and what goes on our website
through our social media channels and to
me it doesn't feel like these platforms
take the same level of responsibility
and that i think is what's going to have
to change in the testimony i'm sure
we'll probably speak to that okay um
we've just got time we've got about 45
seconds anita uh major museums bank back
anti-woke charter could you just sum up
this story for us
well i mean so far we don't really know
much about it all we know is that that
possibly the vna museum the science
museum and a third are backing some
guidelines that might sort of push back
on on some of this the current work
conversation um and so this will be
about recognizing our history for
instance kind of explaining rather than
taking down stuff that is controversial
or um you know and and again grappling
with our colonial path okay we've got
now just a teaser from the telegraph
right now okay anita thank you very much